im Süden der Ukraine genauer gesagt in
saporicia ist unsere ZDF Reporter Tim
Kröger für uns schönen guten Tag Tim am
Wochenende gab es ja teils
widersprüchliche Meldungen zu bachmut ob
die Russen jetzt die Stadt eingenommen
haben und kontrollieren wie schätzt du
die Lage ein
also die Situation rund um bachmut in
bachmut lässt sich leider immer noch
schwer einschätzen es stehen immer noch
beide Aussagen im Raum auf der einen
Seite eben die der russischen der
russischen Truppen die sagen wir haben
bachmut vollständig eingenommen und dann
die ukrainische Seite die sagt das
stimmt nicht wir haben immer noch
Truppen in der Stadt wir halten immer
noch einen kleinen Teil der Stadt bei
der Aussagen lassen sich nicht
überprüfen aber vielleicht ist das auch
gar nicht mehr so relevant ich halte es
beispielsweise für viele interessanter
zu sehen ob der Söldner Chef prigoshi in
seiner Aussage wahr macht und seine
Truppen aus bachmut herauszieht und dann
die Stadt an die reguläre russische
Armee übergibt und das ob das dann
eventuell dazu führt dass die russischen
Truppen im Bach Mut geschwächt werden
wir hören beispielsweise auch dass die
russische Seite gerade neue Soldaten
nach bachmut schickt und dann auf der
anderen Seite ist interessant zu sehen
was an den Rändern von bachmut passiert
also der wird ja ganz offenbar von
ukrainischer Seite seit Tagen
vorgestoßen da sind mehrere Quadratmeter
zurückerobert worden ganz offenbar haben
die ukrainischen Truppen vor die
russischen Truppen in der Stadt von
außen einzugreisen ob das klappt wissen
wir nicht aber ich denke wenn diese
beiden Aspekte wenn wir da etwas mehr
Klarheit haben dann lässt sich die
Situation rund um bachmut auch besser
einschätzen im Moment scheint wirklich
nur klar zu sein dass weiter im bachmut
gekämpft wird das weiter Soldaten
sterben in dieser ohnehin schon sehr
sehr brutalen Schlacht die USA und
weitere NATO-Staaten haben wir am
Wochenende auch weitere Hilfe
versprochen es soll auch F16 Kampfjets
geben wie entscheidend sind die Jets für
Kiew
also ich denke dass wenn diese F16
Kampfjet erst einmal in der Ukraine sind
also geliefert sind dann können sie
durchaus eine entscheidende
Unterstützung für die ukraineische Armee
sein aber das wird aller Voraussicht
nach wahrscheinlich noch ziemlich lange
dauern beispielsweise für die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive die ja jetzt
eigentlich jederzeit erwartet wird
werden diese Kampfjet sehr
wahrscheinlich zunächst einmal nicht zur
Verfügung stehen aber ich glaube dass
allein schon von dieser Möglichkeit dass
diese F16 Kampfbomber irgendwann in der
Ukraine zur Verfügung stehen das davon
schon einen sehr starkes Signal ausgeht
nämlich das Signal dass die westlichen
Alliierten weiterhin bereit sind mit
sehr viel Finanzkraft und auch
langfristig die Ukraine zu unterstützen
und dass sie dabei eigentlich auch keine
Waffengattung mehr ausschließen
Einschätzung live von unserem Reporter
aus der vielen Dank